[Music]
in inconsiderate Muse oh I think I just
heard a story about a man who goes all
the way up to the top of the stairs to
say good night to you that's considered
bad thank you
that's what I do to her I'll go all the
way in the bathtub to kiss you good
night you do that once twice it's cuz
I'd love to feel her butt into your room
good night I go all the way upstairs and
then either say good night to her again
it'll get a good squeeze that's true he
does do such my butt anymore there's a
[ __ ] I squeeze the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] yesterday yes I did you don't feel
it anymore you never touch my butt well
that's the other day because we touch it
that body touch that [ __ ] right now
I'll marry you let me touch your butt
more often all right [ __ ] tell her Tim
your ass woman not a day goes by her
butt does not get come yesterday we were
going to bed like fighting like arguing
yeah and you still was touching my butt
he's talking to me do you fight wall
touch don't fight that hard because
there's a deep underneath it we know
that we're all we're gonna stay together
oh my god you're married you know like
it's not like I love him to about our
ways so we're just like bickering on top
of yeah we're just bickering yeah I love
booty I could grab a booty all day even
when you're mad yep I could smack a
booty all day too you could just ignore
me you just lay on your stomach and I'll
just sleep right on that next time when
we're fighting just bend over and then
we'll stop fighting see isn't that
considerate no she can't have to do any
work like it look that would make me
annoyed if I had to do work too while
we're fighting for you to get a booty
grab like you have to go for that that
make sense okay then don't look at me
when we fight
that's an interesting what her eyes are
so beautiful I was just
no but how am I gonna grab her but if
her butts face the other reach around
but see beautiful eyes can also look
like pissed angry eyes at the same time
yep I don't know I could I would happily
argue with you and [ __ ] all right next
time when I fight I will change places
with ya that's Casey's problem he's not
a pretty woman oh she's gonna be like
The Bachelor Vietnam I like your [ __ ]
oh no it's a minibike submitted by talk
about this okay I guess a Russian
official each in trouble after his
wife's torquing caused a massive traffic
jam his wife's twerking yeah she was
have a nice ass oh [ __ ] you're wearing
Nikki's necklace I was like that's gonna
be too thirsty to rock one of those
necklaces me too I'll be I'll get brandy
oh and even I would love to rock secret
society but you know know your body type
Steve by the time you were fully
incorporated incorporated into this life
secret society was a very limited run we
got all this [ __ ] from China so we
couldn't get a backup but this new line
though made here made an America baby
Stockton baby and I was gonna wear it
after I lost weight because I was a fat
[ __ ] and those long T's don't look good
with a belly for the long team but I was
gonna put it so the ready it's pointless
to promote it right now you can promote
it whatever you want yeah I can't wait
for the new line I love it
rubbing in it to library to this that's
cool that's really cool just wait balls
just wait just wait
alright you just wait alright so anyway
this story here in Russia this wife of a
Russian politician she's a 29 year old
amateur pop singer mmm her stage name is
Oksana she sounds hot
yak sauna like a yak like those cows
yuck
like this doesn't sound hot when you say
just is right like when you said it's
like oh that's kind of sexy and then
Joe's like yak sauna nevermind I just
pictured a Russian yak like [ __ ]
clown some beef [ __ ] plows engine is
should be marveled at yeah so her
husband is a Moscow region Legislative
Assembly deputy and so she decided to
stop this car in the middle of the super
busy perpetually traffic clogged tan
lane highways see what did the ghost
ride the whip huh
and as she started recording your music
video and I'm gonna show you guys a
video clip on that gonna help his
campaign
[Music]
yeah
these are going around
two thing that she was like so nervous
and again through the so nervous
I would be too ran over old boy but look
at all the traffic jams
I couldn't make it to where they have to
go they're doing like a five minute
dance routine during the whole time you
know what I love about it they're
definitely going high-tech with that
GoPro it's weird too because her husband
is a politician in some way whatever he
is I feel like he would have the strings
to pull to like maybe get a permanent
like maybe not and that's that
particular street but somewhere you know
they wanted the cars
oh they drive they could have like set
all of that up and as a politician he's
probably not he's probably not poor you
wouldn't even be talking about this if
that was just a dance routine in a
gymnasium right now what the whole point
is that it was around the traffic
because that's why it's a viral eating
cool all right and then this is her and
her husband oh that looks like a Steve
green photo it's boss really blurry the
eyes are just so whitened yeah this was
a nightclub owner which is a politician
yeah Michael voters like a perfect way
of putting it he's like yeah I own three
Hooters uh-oh he is Russian like I
picture that like you know that's how
they run their vodka vodka vodka I am
elected vodka yeah I have a friend who's
was she was she immigrated here like
maybe like five years ago they're just
telling me like small things about like
Russia and like how the like mayo and
like male dominance is so huge over
there yeah like she says I should just
be chilling like Doozers grab her at a
coffee place I grabbed her by the arm is
sit on her lot on their lap like that
I'm not sure I'm not from Russia but
that's what she told me and she says
like yeah I like men are like very like
machismo like I'm like the [ __ ] of women
you do what I tell you to do yeah and
they're like it's like an extreme
version of catcalling is what they do so
it's like pretty intense out died no
yeah yeah I like Russia from the outside
looking in not to like I'm a quarter
Russian oh she's Filipino friend
professional who's Russian so my great
grandma came from Russia and then
there's like some French on that side
too so my mom's French and Russian
and then my dad slope in Russia such a
fascinating place so I've been to the
airport twice and each time they were
just really I didn't know that I didn't
know this but if they view people
smiling for no reason they think that
they're just more on my ol a lot to
strangers all the time so when I was
there and I was like trying to buy some
food and like trying to buy some magnets
for my collection there I was just like
you're staring at me like hey dude
[ __ ] la man I will smile at people
walking by and then they don't do it and
I'm like will [ __ ] you man yep I get
pissed you - I didn't care I know why do
I care because I'm I'm considerate I
smile at people all the time and they
just look right past it but I don't care
he's about respect that's right it
doesn't matter I know when you give love
Steve you can't expect it in return no I
do you can I want it to be an even
transaction South Pasadena a lot of nice
people to smile though that's why I need
to go to smile I think people get caught
off guard because in LA like if you were
to say hi like if I was if some stranger
just said higher smiled at me right I'll
be like what's your angle man yeah
that's how they are were you trying to
sell when I was in Mexico like
everywhere I went people any person I
pass by they'd be like oh good morning
good afternoon good evening everything
what's up as a Bali and I was just like
why are you talking to me cuz I mean you
think morning good evening how are you
doing here in LA it's like your door
knocks and you're like yeah exactly
who the [ __ ] is he been in order
post-acute I know I always say hi to
people and they were they're always like
no you know yeah apartment complex ly
I'm her neighbor I said hi dude Jesus
Christ right you yeah that's more like
it
like oh that's our neighbor I'll be like
I'm gonna [ __ ] rape you and if they
don't react I'll be like hey I take it
back yeah I wish I never said it I
learned to be a little nicer because of
Muriel she says then I have a a mean
demeanor if I feel like I'm being
threatened which is all the [ __ ] time
like for example like haha but depending
on where you're from the area that I
grew up in was not as nice as the other
areas which I found out as an adult
exists because I wasn't allowed there
yeah you're you're you're me and income
was probably 70 K but around here it's
like 121 130 I mean our median income
was about like 25k pretty [ __ ] low
dude like it was like 25 30 K here like
we're pretty [ __ ] poor yeah she would
notice that if I if I really did it like
somebody for example like when we moved
into our condo South Pasadena is really
nice and I was living in Cape Town
before it came down about that [ __ ]
nice especially when I was living there
like our neighbor would come to the door
and you know they're like the the people
that look after the condo you know
they're putting like a new letter on it
called my door I'm like yeah what's up
she's like why don't you save that guy
like that I was like I don't know it's
kind of mean wasn't it she was like yeah
you always do that and I'm like oh I'm
talking learn how to correct that [ __ ]
yeah I don't know who the guy is so it
just makes me feel like what do you want
yeah well the bugs got one she's like oh
I'm going to put on the letter for your
door either Gascon dude the [ __ ] would
you want yeah so I learned to fix that
stuff dude it's habit dude when I lived
in k-town there was a one of my
neighbors was this Mexican lady and they
had two chickens they had a rooster and
a chicken and and then one day I used to
like say good morning to her every
morning on my way to work and then one
day I I was like oh hey where's your
chicken and she smiled as she went yeah
exactly as you're wiping your face with
the chicken she made you yeah there you
go birds chicken right my nose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]